Jolene Maxwell found guilty in sex
trafficking uh trial this is a guardian
story British former socialite jalaine
Maxwell was found guilty of sex
trafficking or Manhattan federal court
trial late December prosecutor said
Maxwell preyed on vulnerable young girls
manipulated them and served them up to
be sexually abused by Epstein there were
four accusers in this case Jane Kade
Caroline who did not use their full
names and and farmer who did Jane
testified that she was 14 years old 1994
when Epson started a sexually abuser and
that sometimes Maxwell was present about
uh during the abuse at times Maxwell
participate in the abuse there were
hands everywhere Jane recalled of an
encounter with Epstein and Max while the
abuse continued when she was 15 16
Maxwell face up to 65 years in prison
jalaine Maxwell's little black book to
remain Secret After judge warns needles
name drop and it's an independent
needless name drop and by the way who
has the black book Jolene Maxwell's
little black book containing the names
and addresses of nearly 2 000 world
leaders leaders celebrities and alleged
victims room will remain secret
Maxwell's defense attorney came
to an agreement with the prosecute over
the weekend not to release the 97-page
directory to the public judge Allison
Nathan had previously said she wanted to
avoid needless name-dropping during the
trial the book was filled with contact
details of Miss Maxwell and Epstein's
famous friends including prince Andrew
former U.S President Bill Clinton and
Trump and had been mentioned
sporadically during her sex trafficking
trial so I'm sure you being in this
world you've been following the story
what do you know about what's going on
here
oh all right I'm gonna try to make this
I'm gonna try to make this uh fast but
this is a very very nuanced so as an
example the uh the black book being
sealed right well that happened back in
December early December um the black
book is no longer sealed
um it was only sealed in the courtroom
because uh the judge didn't want the
jury getting distracted with a bunch of
super famous names uh that was really
what it came down to uh we've actually
made this very easy for everybody you
can go to Maxwell
trial.deliverfund.org and we have posted
links to the little black book which uh
was leaked by Gawker back in 2015. you
can you can see it there you can see the
flight logs you can see all the evidence
that was entered into court and the
reason we did that was to kind of get
rid of some of the conspiracy theories
now the the little black book what is it
the doj has it
uh it was stolen by a uh by the butler I
believe it was who uh was essentially
using it as an insurance policy the doj
got their hands on it because the butler
tried to then sell it to an undercover
doj FBI agent uh he ended up getting
some consequences for that
but the the black book was an address
book it's no different than the address
book in your phone right I mean Patrick
you've got everybody from CIA people to
Mobsters in your phone right I mean it's
prior to your phone everyone had a
little black book it was called you know
yeah you know you had your Palm Pilot
before that or you know
depending on where you are in the the
technology adoption story it was just an
address book so there's all kinds of
people in there who uh some of them were
up to some but we're up to no good and
some of them were doing some pretty
terrible things and some of them were
you know the freaking handyman who fixed
the hot water here uh right I mean so
it's the where we get focused on the
little black book so it's not a ledger
it's not like a this person came it's
not like the Heidi's Place uh exactly no
go go to it's an address book yeah go
got it go to
maxwelltrial.deliverfund.org and you and
click on the link that says little black
book but it is pretty interesting what
famous names might be in that book well
yeah like yeah the plumber okay the
handyman your friend but like that's the
conversation in the book all right
that's the conversation right but Prince
Andrew's in the book
um Bill Clinton Donald Trump Alec
Baldwin I mean yeah but what's really
interesting don't focus on the black
book focus on the flight logs right
that's what you want to focus on right
and we we posted a uh we posted a link
to the flight logs as well you focus on
the flight logs and who's on there right
and and where they were going so okay we
all know that Epstein Islands right this
this is not this is not Nick's opinion
this is now like fact you're right doj
established fact that there was sex
trafficking happening
um within the uh within the Epstein uh
compound not just compound but within
his ecosystem right because it was the
London house it was uh yeah I mean yeah
townhouse right you had multiple
locations within his ecosystem London
house yeah yeah I mean he has uh um he
had he had I mean it places really all
over the world and so the question is
what was he doing
um where where what was the source of
his funds
because like tell me what his business
was it was a financial advisor wasn't he
was he
was wasn't he what was he though
he was a financier he did he was an
executive producer he was a financier of
films and and other projects but that's
one of the things that they can't and
I've read uh I know where you're going
with this the guy died being worth
around 600 million to a billion dollars
but nobody knows how he made his money
yeah
financial advisor Nancy Pelosi does
I mean it's it's a it that's the
question that needs to be asked right
and then if where do you get that kind
of power well so what's what don't we
know like what so what here's the
question because everything you just
said so far I followed all the stories
so far on on what you what you covered
what don't we know that's important to
know the flight log yep I I agree we
need to know what the flight log is on
who went on there you know all of that
stuff I totally get right there you know
with uh folks that have yeah I've seen
this but what I want to know is what
what do we need to find out next and the
information that we need to find out are
we really going to find out or you know
the other day I said Donald Trump Jr
post a picture saying you know uh uh uh
uh jelaine Maxwell the day she was born
and then he said two weeks you know like
yeah she's not going to be here with the
next two weeks so is she gonna plead
guilty the way that uh Epstein did
that's right so what's what don't we
know who's hiding does the government
know what's going on are they holding
back what's going on is there any of the
you hear the conspiracies about they're
trying to hold back from people finding
God because a lot of people would go
down what's really going on behind
closed doors so uh just just because it
uh so all right conspiracy theories uh
yeah you bet there are some powerful
people who are are starting to starting
to sweat and uh to to think that we have
uh equal access to the legal system in
this country is is just not true because
if you have money you have more access
to the legal system that's just the way
that it works
um so anybody who uh anybody who has a
lot of money who might potentially have
something to to be concerned about has
the ability to get in front of that
um so like let's not kid ourselves into
thinking that they don't
um what is the doj going to do about
that I don't know what we need and what
we don't have or at least what I have
not seen publicly the doj might have
this is we need a full Financial audit
back to the beginning of time of
Epstein's accounts that's what we need
where did the money come from right
because I think you're going to see a
decent amount of outflow that's that's
what I want to know but there you go I
think most of your outflow is going to
be just fuel right is going to be rent
it's going to be those types of things
sure I think most of your inflow like
that's what I'm interested in is where
did that money come from you make a
great point and the point about power
you were talking about power and it's
basically was a were these nefarious
sexual encounters really the equivalent
of EX Epstein making bones as the mafia
would say yeah on other people and that
became his Labyrinth source of power
right because it all goes like this and
so now he's got control and I agree with
you it's like where did the money come
from what was the money actually used
for you know really used for because the
obvious outflows are going to be you
know service maintenance jet fuel all
the things for all these locations okay
well what was going on
we'll look at I mean right there uh line
nine on the uh on the flight log right
Bill Clinton plus four secret service
two males one female and then a bunch of
initials gmskap yeah so but but there's
your point like all right so what what
was happening there but then go go up
um to uh flight number 51 in uh Cindy
Lopper yeah I saw that go down the next
one right so like and that's where I
think we need no no you were on the go
back on the same page you were at line
one yeah that's where we need to be a
little bit careful on the first page
control Zoom 51 Cindy Lopper and uh
or yeah Cindy Loper and then above that
Cindy Lopez or maybe that was Cindy
Lopez and what do they do they go back
and they find the initials and they
identify who that person likely is and
they start questioning those people is
that how it works I don't know what the
doj is doing just because just because
your name is on here doesn't mean you
committed a crime right right but it's
an it's a decent indicator that that
you're right that deserves some
questions so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]